you may have heard about this story this
story about Balenciaga the fashion brand
Balenciaga we've got some info here from
the daily wire parents erupted in
Outrage over fashion brand Balenciaga
using young children to advertise what
one critic dubbed bondage teddy bear
purses the high-end brand is known for
its outrageous fashion and is often worn
by celebrities like Kim Kardashian model
Bella Hadid and actress Nicole Kidman
the daily wire was able to confirm the
following photos were on valenciaga's
website as of Monday morning here's a
couple of the images I mean is this
stuff really for kids what are we doing
with these teddy bears bondage teddy
bears with kids and it's like what is
all of this stuff but wokeness has
infected everything and people think
anything is okay right it's just so
bizarre we have to put up a warning we
got the warning going you're about to
see the harpies on The View they
talked about Balenciaga and sort of
maybe made a little sense related to it
and kind of maybe sort of I'll let you
decide what's going on
I clearly just taste
in this moment so there's this there's
growing anti-lgbtq sentiment right now
and it how it's Being Framed is as
portraying you know trans people as
groomers this is a term you'll hear on
the far right they're groomers this is
where you get the anti-drag queen stuff
that we're seeing so Balenciaga played
right into their hands by having kids in
a sexualized manner carrying something
that represents you know sex acts I
think it was a really bad misstep at a
moment where it's just kind of a
dangerous time to even give Credence to
those kind of insane takes yeah I mean
we can't even show the picture because
it's so distasteful but what's also very
distasteful is like Balenciaga lately I
mean their stuff is just ugly I mean the
bag that the little girl is holding is
ugly do you remember when Kim K was
dressed in Balenciaga for the game
look at that they look like a bat or
something I mean I think I gave them a
little too much credit that they made
some sense look they make some sense in
that okay the pictures were gross but
their analysis of what's going on here
really makes no sense um first off uh
Allison farra she's the fake
conservative that was talking at first
um so she's the one that's allowed to be
a little bit on the right but she always
have to like go after Republicans on the
show it's just such an absolute farce
um she says she talks about the growing
anti-lgbtq sentiment you guys know my
feelings about these these letter
alphabet nonsense
um these letters make no sense I have
nothing more in common with a trans
person than a straight person does
they've just combined all of these
things to take the individual out of all
of these things there is not growing
anti-lgbtq violence there really isn't
what people are concerned about is
pushing the gender stuff on children and
so she's claiming oh they call them all
groomers no one's calling all gay people
or even all trans people groomers
they're calling the people who want to
endlessly talk to Children about sex and
gender identity groomers I don't know
what other word it would be if you were
a say third grade teacher and you were
supposed to be teaching the Kid 2 plus 2
equals four and instead after school you
meet with the little boy and you call
him by a girl's name and then you hide
that information from the parents for
months and months and people at the
school call him the girl's name but you
don't want the parents to know I don't
know what else to call you besides
Gruber I probably could find some other
words but we will get demonetized so no
one is saying that that's what all gay
people want it's it's a damn shame
what's going on here because for all for
the obvious equality that gay people
have it is now the radical woke leftists
that are that are instigating some hate
around them because of this very
nonsense